that in online chess if you lose the  control of the position it's so  difficult to get it back yeah it's uh  i think that uh over the board maybe  it's easier to somehow defend the end  and queen even is on the board here it's  much easier to attack yeah because it's  so easy to focus on the attack while  while defending in online rapid or or  this is already blitz yeah with a few  seconds on the clock bullet it's  very very difficult  and i don't even see a way to escape the  mate anymore okay he's trying to create  the e4 square but there has to be  something so you go queen f2 king  g4  yeah and then okay g5 check  for g5  yeah just g5 and then bishop f7 meto any  any  wow but peter this really puts ding  lyran in a bit of danger now for  qualification and it of course pushes  andres pianko's chances into the  knockouts  absolutely i mean this is this is a  massive win for juan day